hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
the 2013 candidates tournament on the
white end Magnus Carlson playing against
Boris
gelfand we have a Sicilian
Defense roselo attack E6 castles and now
if black questions the bishop while this
Knight is not defended by a
piece white will take and saddle black
with Double T
pawns black first connects Knights and
is now ready to question the
bishop white is no longer interested in
meeting A6 with this
capture so he puts himself in position
to go
elsewhere white is timely on this move
five Rook E1 is not just about
centralizing a piece F1 is now vacant so
that the bishop can go back home it's
other option weren't
appealing unstable obstructs the center
Pawn obstructs
pieces D5 e takes D Knight recaptures
the bishop is ready to
play Carlson plays in the
center move 8 D4 what are some of your
thoughts when you see this move feel
free to pause the video give it 30
seconds okay I'll just be noting a few
things for right now and in a few moves
I'll be highlighting what I think the
big pitcher idea is behind this
advance so some things you may say
there's tension between the pawns and
there's an intersection Square on D4 two
Defenders two attackers you may say
White's trying to make things Dynamic
open things up while his King is cozy
and blacks is in the center and one last
note for now at least this particular
pawn exchange is
inevitable let's get a few more moves in
the Knight Retreats so that the queen
increases the pressure on
D4 neither side is so quick to release
this tension each side wants one another
to initiate the exchange so that they
can recapture and improve a piece in
comes Bishop E3 more pressure on
C5 White's not concerned about Knight D5
or Knight G4 bothering the bishop a fine
reply a good reply in both cases is
Bishop
G5 in this game we have C takes
D Knight recapture white has just
improved a hair black puts himself in
position to do similar should white take
on
C6 here we are on this move 11 I wonder
if you can spot Carlson's next move what
move would you play here would you
consider to be a healthy
move feel free to pause the
video okay an additional note behind
move 8
D4 is that Carlson was creating a
queenside
majority we're working here with A3
versus
2 he is not developing his Queen Knight
to C3
he's taking into account this majority
on this move 11 C4 it's in motion a big
square is taken away from the King
Knight and next up he's ready to tuck
the Knight right
behind if you're looking for a game that
does an excellent job of highlighting a
3-2 Queens side majority this is the one
to have a closer look at really an
excellent
game we continue Knight takes Knight
Bishop takes Knight Bishop C6 hitting
the minor pieces out prep work for the
majority denied
A5 Queen D3 new square for the queen
Rook also White's looking to coordinate
with the most menacing white
piece and that is this bishop on D4 the
one that points towards is the heart of
the kingside structure right around the
corner Queen
G3 castles Rook a to D1 Queen
C7 Bishop
E5 Queen B6 Queen G3 the B
Pawn
poison in the game it is Rook F to d8 if
Queen takes
B2 we would have Knight D5 too many
problems to solve
no good reply
here all right Rook F to d8 in this game
the reply Rook takes Rook Bishop C7 is
not a good idea going for this
imbalance it prefers black two Rooks
outweighing the queen black has good
coordination that's the main thing you
would look at in going for such an
imbalance being down the
queen okay first we have the Rook
exchange that variation I just
highlighted helps us to understand why
black does not recapture with the Rook
here Bishop C7 would hit in this game it
is Queen takes
Rook Carlson gets to the open file the
only open file and this is where black
now goes wrong in the game Queen B6 is
played very easy I would say to go wrong
that seems very
natural what is considered best Queen
f8 safeguarding
G7 and this frees up the Knight ways to
improve from here H6 Rook to d8 calls it
around
even now with Queen B6 watch these next
few moves closely these next few moves
allow Carlson to advance his Queen side
majority First bishop D4 the queen
better not go to the defile Bishop takes
Knight Queen's in trouble she moves
forward this is really the the best that
black can do in this position Queen B3
seems like she's cozy there for the
moment but not quite Rook D3 immediately
questioning the Queen the Knight is
ready to jump
we have two pawns that are both poisoned
they're both
indirectly defended we know what happens
on Queen takes B2 what's happening in
this position if Queen takes
C4 in the game the queen goes to
C2 if Queen takes C4 here white can take
on
F6 and after the recapture there's a
check and there goes the queen
so Queen
C2 now we get to advance the
majority
B4 these last two moves Bishop D4 and
Rook D3 have pulled the queen away from
controlling this B4 Advance B4 is
available you cannot take twice a takes
B A takes B don't take on B4 you're
going to lose the the
Knight before you go before Carlson
played B4 you really do have to factor
uh some things in here because yes you
are getting your majority going you're
now working with a two to one but at the
same time you have activated this Rook
are you okay with doing this also are
you okay with these last moves Bishop D4
Rook D3 inviting the queen this deep in
your
house black cannot follow up by putting
the Rook on the first rank here this is
something that had to be weighed before
playing
B4 why is Rook A1 not a good move here
he can capture on F6 this is one reason
why can capture on F6 and after the
recapture there's a back rank problem
mate soon enough so the black Rook
has a responsibility the bishop has a
responsibility where do we go from here
it is Knight H5 now this next
sequence you have to see a few moves
ahead Carlson
saw that after Queen E5 Bishop F6 Queen
takes Knight Bishop takes Bishop Rook
takes bishop and queen
takes Knight he saw that in this
position he has a very good
move how would you react to this
position here how would you react to
this threat on The Rook feel free to
pause the
video all right are any of you tempted
by action on the king's side when the
bishop and queen was coordinated there
are we still focused on the king side
Rook H4 is is that a good way to go
computer says no you go with H6 you
could even ignore the threat even says
be fine giving up this pawn and run away
here this goes nowhere if you form a
battery on the H file what is absolute
best the one that keeps white in a
winning
position Queen
A5 forget about the king side there's a
back rank weakness
and queen A5 takes advantage of it we're
not moving with the Rook we're attacking
an unprotected piece and saying I dare
you take my queen and it's going to be
mate in
two so this forces The Rook off of the
open file and it has to crawl up into a
ball and now the queen is planted on B6
White's position is excellent look at
the coordination better Rook better
Queen everything is defended the queen
is in White's house but not coordinated
with any other black
piece All Right Where Do We Go From Here
E5 it does suggest Rook to
d8 in this game it's Rook
D1 a flight square is
produced B5 the majority continues to
roll and and the followup here Carlson
puts the queen on F6 and this renews
back rank mating ideas he takes away
that flight Square from black what is
considered better is to get a flight
Square in and then put the queen on
C7 suggests keeping an
eye on these two pawns and next looking
to advance with C5 so some Advantage bit
of an Advantage is given away here with
this move as appealing as it looks
planting the queen in this hole on
F6 from here H5 H4 each side well white
has a flight Square now black has an
additional flight
Square Bishop
F5 Rook D5 the E Pawn
Falls but black now has good pieces all
of a sudden the bishop is on E6
and The Rook is able to activate right
around the corner for
black we have this uh increased pressure
on the pinned Bishop how to get out of
this
pin Retreat Queen E2 next up there's
Rook to
D1 black does not have time to form a
battery on the back
rank if if Rook A1 in this position
there would follow Rook check King H7
and queen E5 white can afford to give up
this bishop with check because in this
position right here there's no good way
to get at the
king this check is covered by the queen
and there's a big problem on h8 this
bishop does not help defend against this
threat F6 there's Queen C7 leading to
mate in a
couple so not so fast Rook instead we
have King H7 this now gives white time
to unpin the
bishop now that it's unpinned the queen
gets back on the
offensive targets the B
Pawn and in this
position Rook A1 is played
and from here on out it's considered
winning for
white the only move to stay in the game
apparently not very human at all is Rook
A7 now if you play Rook A7 you have to
know you could be kicked computer says
this is still even
is or white just has a a small Advantage
with Rook A2 Queen Queen takes Queen
takes B7 Rook B2 and now there are these
ideas of Bishop G4 and if the Rook
leaves the back rank black gets there
and if the Rook leaves defensive D4 the
queen could go here
targeting F2 not at all easy to see a
variation like
this okay in this one it is Rook A1 we
get a rook Exchange
and from here some
calculation we first get going with the
pawns and after Queen C3 he can take on
B2 black is going to win this
bishop but these
pawns are very dangerous we have Queen
E1 this stops the queen from getting to
E4 if the queen could get to E4 that
would stop Bishop C4 so we got a pin and
defense of
E4 he continues to
advance if some pin like this is here
black simply gets out of it Queen B1 and
then next up Bishop C4 soon this bishop
will be
tracked in the game it is B6 he advances
the more dangerous past Pawn I consider
the B Pawn more dangerous because this
promotion square a dark Square this guy
cannot defend that promotion
Square so this is the faster
Pawn from here Bishop C4 he has it all
calculated Queen F3 he is okay losing a
piece with check because these guys are
just too
good Queen B1 B7 Queen B5 C6
Bishop D5 and just one more
move Queen
G3 black
resigns everything is covered G2 even if
there was coordinated pressure on that
no problem Queen's covering everything
is glued together King is cozy Queen
from G3 supports B8 equals Queen next no
good reply here for black
what did you think of this
one anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comments section below I hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care
bye